Fünf Tage, 200 km, bis -20 °C.
Mit dem Huskygespann
quer durch die Wildnis Lapplands.
Vier Frauen und ein Mann
erfüllen sich ihren Traum.
Begonnen hat alles vor zwei Tagen
auf der Huskyfarm des finnischen
Hundeführers Juho Ylipiessa.
Ihr müsst euch kennenlernen, nicht?
He, aber brav sein.
Jede und jeder ist selbst
für sein Gespann verantwortlich.
Vieles ist neu, die Gruppe ist mit
all den Aufgaben noch überfordert.
"Was mache ich jetzt?"
Es ist irgendwie so: "Was mache ich
mit den Hunden, dem Gepäck?"
Ich fühlte mich am Anfang
auch irgendwie hilflos.
Das Team ist am nächsten Morgen
zu langsam unterwegs.
Eigentlich hätten wir ganz schnell
aufstehen und arbeiten sollen.
Fertig!
Die Verspätung hat Konsequenzen.
Armin hat seine Hunde nicht im Griff.
Sie haben gekämpft.
Die beiden Starken
haben einander am Kopf gepackt.
Alle auf einem Haufen und ich
wusste zwischendurch nicht, was tun.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Tag 2. Anfang Dezember.
Die Gruppe ist nach der Aufregung
des Morgens endlich unterwegs.
Hundeführer Juho hofft,
dass sich die Huskys beruhigen,
wenn sie endlich laufen können.
Und tatsächlich:
Friedlich zieht auch das Fünfer-
gespann des Brunnenmeisters Armin
durch die Abgeschiedenheit Finnlands.
Ihre Schlitten haben die
fünf Schweizer schon besser im Griff.
Jeder führt Proviant und Gepäck
selber mit, bis zu 60 kg.
Der erste Stopp
nach wenigen Kilometern.
Hund Cooper hat sich
beim Kampf am Morgen verletzt.
Sicherheitshalber
nimmt ihn Juho aus dem Gespann.
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Jetzt schont er ihn,
bis wir die grosse Pause haben,
und schaut,
denn er hat eine Verletzung am Lauf.
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Ich kann nicht viel sehen.
Die Wunde ist nicht gross,
nur ein Kratzer.
Nur ein Kratzer auf der Haut.
Und das
an unserem Unabhängigkeitstag!
Am 6. Dezember 1917
löste sich Finnland
aus der russischen Vorherrschaft.
Seither ist dieser Tag
der finnische Nationalfeiertag.
Juho verabreicht
dem verletzten Cooper eine Tablette
und gönnt dem Tier
eine Verschnaufpause.
Die anderen Hunde wollen weiter.
Ich gebe ihm
entzündungshemmende Mittel.
Es ist wirklich
nur ein kleiner Schnitt.
Es sieht nicht schlimm aus.
Ich nehme ihn in meine Notfallkiste
auf den Schlitten
und wir schauen am Abend,
was wir machen.
Geht es ihm am Morgen nicht besser,
muss ihn jemand abholen kommen.
* Jaulen *
Ja, ja, Ballack.
Du hast Ballack,
mit ihm reichen auch vier Hunde.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Mit 39 kg ist Ballack
der grösste Hund aus Juhos Rudel.
Schau, wie schön. Siehst du's?
Hei!
So orange, so ...
Schön, nicht?
Das tut bis weit hinein gut.
* Juchzen *
Dem Alltag entfliehen,
eine Auszeit nehmen
und seine Träume leben -
das wirkt Wunder.
Für die Softwaretestmamagerin Silvia
ist dieses Abenteuer
eine grosse Herausforderung.
Vor vier Jahren
ist sie an Parkinson erkrankt.
Perfekt. Wie geht's dir, Silvia?
- Gut.
Good?
- Yes.
Das war wohl der schwierigste
Streckenabschnitt der ganzen Woche.
Ich weiss noch nicht so genau,
wie ich mein Gewicht einsetzen soll,
um richtig zu steuern.
Jetzt haben wir
etwas zu Essen verdient.
Wie immer:
Zuerst gibt's Wurst für die Hunde.
Yeah.
Juhos wichtigste Regel:
Die Hunde kommen immer zuerst.
Es gibt zuerst für die Hunde zu
essen, bevor es für euch was gibt.
Stimmt.
Noch ein bisschen weiter.
Hier auf die Seite.
Michelle, die Physiotherapeutin,
versorgt sie,
bevor sie an sich selbst denkt.
* Jaulen *
Der starke Ballack und Armin freunden
sich langsam an und werden zum Team.
So können sie nichts mehr ziehen.
Sie können den Schlitten nicht
ziehen, wenn man sie rausnimmt.
Und wie geht es Cooper
im fahrenden Krankenzimmer?
Er war einfach zu vorwitzig.
Cooper ist ein Punk.
Er ist
ein anderthalbjähriger Frechdachs.
Normalerweise haben andere Hunde
Respekt vor Ballack.
Aber der hier war dumm genug,
Ballack herauszufordern.
Und natürlich hat er verloren.
- (Armin) Ist das sein Charakter?
Cooper ist noch jung und sucht noch
seinen Platz in der Hundehierarchie.
Sie probieren es einfach aus.
Er hat das vorher noch nie gemacht.
Aber ich habe schon bemerkt,
dass er seinen Platz
innerhalb des Rudels sucht -
drum hat er Ballack herausgefordert.
Das war nicht sehr klug.
Diesen Luxus hat man nicht oft
im Leben, mit so schönen Tieren.
Mein Gefühl ist, ich konnte
schon eine Bindung aufbauen,
aber von ihnen her ist es ...
So stark ist es wohl nicht.
Aber sie freuen sich,
wenn man kommt und sie wertschätzt.
Prost.
Der erste Augenblick der Ruhe
für die Abenteurer.
Ich liess gestern den ganzen Tag
Revue passieren und muss sagen,
ab den ersten 2-3 km
wurde ich recht emotional -
alles ... prasselte auf mich nieder.
Man fährt plötzlich einfach
mit seinem eigenen Schlitten
durch einen wunderschönen Wald,
es funktioniert alles,
man spürt eine ...
tiefe Zufriedenheit,
man ist glücklich.
Man ist völlig losgelöst von allem.
Natürlich,
die Umgebung trägt einiges dazu bei,
dass man nicht an den Alltag denkt.
Auch Silvia geniesst die Zeit
mit den Hunden in vollen Zügen -
und vergisst
die Sorgen ihres Alltags.
Dass ich glücklich bin.
Ganz einfach.
Einfach einen Moment ...
Jetzt rührt es mich.
Die Krankheit zu vergessen.
Ich habe es fast vergessen.
Ich spüre nicht viel. Nur wenn ich
die Tabletten wieder nehmen muss.
Aber ich vergesse es völlig,
es ist nicht mehr im Vordergrund.
Es ist ... irgendwo weit hinten.
Das wünschte ich mir.
Und es ist super.
Ich bin extrem glücklich.
I'm so happy. Dabei ...
- (Juho) I can see it. Ich auch.
Ich vergesse meine Parkinson-Erkran-
kung, und das ist so wichtig. Danke!
Schon gut.
Und ich habe vergessen, dass du
diese Erkrankung überhaupt hast.
Wir fuhren diesen steilen Hügel
runter und ich dachte:
"Ist das wirklich Silvia?"
Ich bin eine Kämpferin.
Aufgeben ist keine Option.
Dieser Hügel war anspruchsvoller
als alles, was noch kommt.
Es kommen noch grössere Anstiege,
aber die sind viel einfacher.
Aufgeben kommt nicht infrage.
- Das ist die richtige Einstellung.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Juho hat wohl aus taktischen Gründen
etwas untertrieben
mit den bevorstehenden Anstrengungen.
Vor dem Team liegt
ein steiler Anstieg über 200 m.
Es ist gegen 15 Uhr
und bereits stockdunkel.
Jetzt kommt nochmals ein
grosser Anstieg, dann eine Abfahrt.
Wir fahren hoch, so schnell es geht,
stoppen oben nicht
und fahren wirklich langsam
hinunter, alle zusammen.
(Armin) Okay.
Das ist eine ganz wilde Horde.
* Bellen *
Die sind einfach so wild
und doch so liebe Kerle.
* Abenteuerliche Trommelklänge *
* Juho ruft und pfeift Kommandos. *
(Juho) He, Frauen,
haltet die Augen offen!
Die Hunde sind stark,
doch bei so einem Anstieg
müssen die Teilnehmer mithelfen.
Sie dürfen dabei ihren Schlitten
auf keinen Fall verlieren.
Go! Komm.
Auch Armin bleibt
trotz besonders starkem Gespann
die Anstrengung nicht erspart.
Die ehemalige Profi-Bobfahrerin
Michelle ist voll in ihrem Element.
Wie früher - am liebsten
würde ich mehrmals hoch und runter,
es war unglaublich. Wahnsinn.
Das Tempo, Gewicht verlagern,
rechts, links, dann rennen - super.
Verrückt, was die leisten.
Und v.a. ...
... mit so vielen Kilos
hinten drauf.
Und sie wollen immer weiter,
wenn man wartet.
Das sind wilde Kerle.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Jetzt trippeln sie wieder.
Achtung.
In der finnischen Dunkelheit,
die zu dieser Jahreszeit
Anfang Dezember rund 20 Std. dauert,
brauchen die Abenteurer
v.a. eine gute Koordination.
* Armin ächzt. *
Jetzt haben wir den wieder drin,
scheisse.
Ach.
Um 17 Uhr
erreichen alle das Nachtlager -
heute ohne weitere Zwischenfälle.
(Armin) Hey, hey, hey. Geht's noch?
Ich bin gerade etwas traurig,
dass wir schon da sind -
wir hätten von mir aus
2-3 Std. weiterfahren können.
Es war so schön!
Tipptopp, voll cool!
Ich bin hellauf begeistert.
Langsam sitzen die Handgriffe,
und die Hunde werden sofort versorgt.
So.
Bravo, Mädchen.
Was für ein Durcheinander
ihr gemacht habt!
Gib die doppelte Menge Wurst.
- (Armin) Wirklich?
Ja, es war ein langer Tag
und es wird eine kalte Nacht.
Sie brauchen viel Energie. Und
dann füttern wir sie nach 1-2 Std.
Beim Zelt
machen wir einen neuen Rekord!
(Silvia) Ich bin gespannt,
wie viele Kilometer das heute waren.
Barbara
ist für das Hundefleisch zuständig.
Ich zeige Euch, wo es Wasser gibt.
(Barbara) Wasser schöpfen
geht schneller als Schnee schmelzen.
Es kocht schon.
(Juho) Wir holen jetzt mehr Wasser.
- Wirklich? Aber der Topf ist heiss.
It's not that bad.
- Holt er es da hinten?
Ja. Ich gehe mit.
- Und ich hacke fröhlich weiter.
Ich bin
der Orientierungssinn in Person.
Juho zeigt Silvia,
wo er eine Quelle entdeckt hat.
Es gibt hier überall Wasser,
wir müssen nur klares finden.
Es schmeckt gut, solange
nicht zu viel Dreck reinkommt.
(Barbara)
Ah, wir müssten mehr haben.
(Englisch) Wir brauchen mehr.
(Juho) Ja, ich habe einige grosse
Behälter auf meinem Schlitten.
Es gibt auch eine kleine Quelle.
Hier hat es immer Wasser.
Wir können sogar
unser Trinkwasser von dort nehmen.
(Barbara) Wow.
Dann warten wir.
Ja, der Geschmack war gut,
nicht erdig. - Good.
Ich habe ihnen gerade gesagt,
so viel Arbeit hatte ich
das ganze letzte Jahr über nicht.
Nach dem Morgen lief alles gut.
Super. Keine Unfälle mehr.
Ich glaube,
jetzt beginnt es sich einzuspielen.
Was ist am Morgen passiert?
Die Hunde
hatten einfach zu viel Energie,
das hat selbst mich erstaunt.
Normalerweise
muss ich die Leute nicht warnen:
"Pass auf, die Hunde
könnten miteinander kämpfen!"
Ich hatte noch nie
so viel Durcheinander am Anfang.
Ich weiss, es gibt im Moment
Hündinnen, die läufig werden.
Das war vielleicht der Grund.
Normalerweise bellen die Hunde
einfach und wollen loslaufen.
Aber in der Paarungszeit
geht bei den Rüden
der Testosteronspiegel hoch.
Wir müssen einfach versuchen,
die Hunde
am Start ruhig zu behalten.
Juho
schaut nach dem verletzten Cooper.
Ich bin fast sicher,
es sah am Anfang viel schlimmer aus,
als es war.
Es ist nur ein kleiner Schnitt.
Die Verletzung geht nicht tief,
nicht bis auf die Muskeln
oder das Fleisch.
Solange wir die Wunde sauber halten,
sollte er morgen laufen können.
Ich habe ihm
keine Schmerzmittel gegeben,
weil ich wissen wollte,
ob er Schmerzen hat und hinkt.
Mit den Medikamenten
würde er auf jeden Fall laufen.
Willst du was sagen?
Dieser Kerl hier ist elf Jahre alt
und schon locker 30'000 km
mit mir gelaufen.
About 30'000 km with me
on the trail.
Jetzt gibt's eine kleine Massage
für den alten Herrn,
gegen den steifen Rücken.
Ja, das ist der richtige Ort.
Nach Tagen wie diesen freuen sie
sich auf die heisse Fleischsuppe.
Erst nachdem sich
die Hunde sattgefressen haben,
dürfen die Teilnehmer an sich denken.
Sie bekommen selber geschossenes
Elchfleisch aus Juhos Jagd.
(Silvia)
Ja, es war körperlich nicht easy.
(Martina) Ich bewundere dich,
Silvia. Also eigentlich uns alle.
(Barbara) Ja. Ich sagte es vorhin
auch: diese Ausdauer, die sie zeigt.
(Silvia) Aufgeben ist keine Option.
(Michelle) Mir ging's heute
viel besser als gestern,
jeder hat seine kleinen Aufgaben.
Und es ist auch mit den Hunden so.
Du lernst sie besser kennen und
kannst sie irgendwie einschätzen.
Es gibt einen,
der immer rennt und führt,
ein anderer wartet eher ab.
Sie sind vom Charakter her
unterschiedlich.
(Martina) Gestern hatten wir
eine Art Date mit den Hunden,
lernten uns einen Tag lang kennen.
Heute sind wir in einer Beziehung.
(Alle) Schön.
Am vierten Tag
heiraten wir wahrscheinlich,
und was am fünften Tag passiert,
möchte ich nicht wissen!
Juho, meinst du,
die Hunde kennen uns schon?
Ich glaube,
die Hunde gewöhnen sich an euch.
Es ist schon der zweite Tag.
Sie sind immer um dieselbe Person,
die ihnen das Fressen gibt.
(Barbara) Ha, dann kennen sie mich!
(Juho) Ja, bei ihnen
läuft vieles über das Essen.
Sie funktionieren relativ einfach.
Wer sie füttert,
ist für sie quasi Gott.
Ho, ho, ho!
Hier ist der Samichlaus!
Heute, am 6. Dezember, ist nicht nur
finnischer Nationalfeiertag.
(Michelle) So süss! - (Martina) Da-
rum erwähntest du den Samichlaustag!
Schmutzli und ich
haben euch etwas mitgebracht.
(Barbara) Da sind wir aber gespannt.
- (Silvia) Setzt euch.
Im Flieger
habe ich schon ein wenig gedichtet,
und nachdem ich euch besser
kennengelernt hatte, schrieb ich.
(Martina) Das hast du
also geschrieben! So süss.
"Armin, der einzige Mann,
der im Notfall auch jagen kann."
(Barbara) So süss. - (Silvia) Es
wurde aber nur ein Zweizeiler.
"Barbara,
die hübsche Mutter mit drei Kind,
herzlich, offen und ein Wirbelwind."
- (Barbara) Du bist ja süss!
"Michelle,
die auf den Kufen Profi war,
tiefgründig legt sie uns
einfachste Denklösungen dar."
"Martina, unser tierliebendes Küken,
wird uns mit Selbstvertrauen
am Ende der Reise entzücken."
(Barbara) Jawohl, nicht? So süss!
- (Martina) Der ist aber sackstark.
Du bekommst vom Samichlaus
ein Wärmepad.
Vielen Dank.
- Das passende Geschenk.
"Silvia, die immer denkt so positiv,
wird im dunklen Norden kreativ."
Ja, wirklich.
(Englisch)
"Juho, unser Führer auf der Tour,
ob runter oder rauf -
er hat einen langen Schnauf."
It's easy.
(Barbara) Das ist ja mega cool!
* Johlen *
Morgen läuft es gleich wie heute.
Wir sollten um 6 Uhr aufstehen.
Denn wir sind etwas langsam.
Und wir sollten
noch effizienter werden,
nicht herumtrödeln.
- (Barbara) We heard that.
Eine Person kümmert sich
um den Kocher für das Hundefutter
und bleibt auch dort.
Eine macht das Teewasser
und geht nicht weg.
Ich nenne jetzt keine Namen,
aber schaut wirklich,
dass ihr kontinuierlich neuen Schnee
in den Ofen hineinschaufelt,
damit die Flamme
immer gross genug bleibt.
Und das Andere -
das hat selbst mich erstaunt:
Die Hunde
haben eine wahnsinnige Energie.
Das ist zwar toll,
wenn es ums Rennen geht,
aber vor dem Start
kann es gefährlich werden.
Sie sind so aufgeladen am Morgen.
Es geht noch,
solange sie an der Nachtleine sind,
aber sobald ihr ihnen
das Laufgeschirr anzieht,
geht der Energiepegel hoch.
(Alle) Mhm.
Like we saw this morning.
Ballack war wahrscheinlich
noch nie in einen Streit verwickelt.
Er hat Cooper hart rangenommen.
Ich habe nicht gesehen,
wie es angefangen hat,
aber ich bin sicher,
Cooper hat ihn provoziert.
Und am Schluss
musste ich ihn den ganzen Tag
auf dem Schlitten hinterherziehen.
Passt von jetzt an auf am Morgen.
Bellen ist in Ordnung.
Wenn sie mit dem Schwanz wedeln
und glücklich sind, ist es okay.
Aber sobald ihr hört,
dass der Ton ändert,
wenn sie aggressiv werden
und ihre Freunde mustern:
"Was machst denn du?"
Wenn sie anfangen,
einander anzuschreien -
unterbindet es sofort.
Zeigt ihnen: Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Denn in einem nächsten Schritt
wird jemand verletzt.
Und wir sind aufgeschmissen,
wenn die Hälfte des Teams
bei mir in der Notfallbox landet.
Also ich jedenfalls.
Sonst habt ihr es gut gemacht.
Auch das Fahren.
Die Temperatur ist deutlich gefallen,
es sind jetzt eisige -20 °C.
* Sphärische Klänge *
(Barbara) Immer dieser Geruch
am Morgen auf leeren Magen ...
Die fünf Abenteurer
haben schon wieder verschlafen.
Sie sind fast 1 Std. zu spät dran.
Es ist schon fast 7 Uhr.
(Martina) Es knistert immerhin.
- Schon fast geschafft.
(Martina) Super.
- Wir sind ein bisschen verspätet.
Man kann auch in der Wildnis
gut verschlafen.
Wir reden alle davon, wir kämen
ohne Handy, und am Schluss ...
(Martina) Ich besitze effektiv
keinen Wecker ausser dem Handy,
und wenn das nicht geht ...
(Michelle)
Und hell wird es auch nicht.
Und gestern haben die Hunde
um 6.30 Uhr noch schön gejault -
gestern
hatten wir einen Hundewecker.
Die Schweizer Uhr
hat nicht funktioniert.
Sie ist ihrem Ruf
nicht gerecht geworden.
Der Alarm ist nicht losgegangen.
Ich war der einzige, der wach war.
Von ihnen kam kein Lebenszeichen.
(Armin) Das sehen wir gleich.
- (Michelle) Noch etwas rüber.
Das ist gut. Holen wir
die Zeit wieder rein. - Locker.
Hast du gut geschlafen?
Wir machen heute
keine keine lange Mittagsrast,
denn wir müssen noch im Tageslicht
den grossen Hügel hochkommen.
Wir füllen die Thermosflaschen
und essen unterwegs ein Sandwich.
Heute steht die Königsetappe an
mit dem Aalistunturi,
dem höchsten Punkt der Tour -
einem Hügel
mit einem harten Aufstieg auf 200 m.
Es sieht gut aus.
Es ist jetzt etwa 8.30 Uhr.
Sie essen Frühstück,
das Zelt ist leergeräumt,
die Hunde wurden früh gefüttert,
so um 7 Uhr.
Ich bin wirklich erfreut
über diese Steigerung.
Jetzt muss ich mich
mit meinem Zelt beeilen,
damit ich nicht die lahme Ente bin!
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Auch das Anspannen
läuft heute schon viel besser.
Der hier ist der dickere.
Juhos Worte haben gewirkt.
Komm!
* Knurren *
Hey, Dally! Fertig!
Fertig.
Dann nehme ich euch beide
halt auseinander.
Hopp. Achtung, Fuss.
I'm sorry, my friend.
Ist gut?
Ist es hier oben?
Ich habe etwas Respekt,
weil es mir heute
nicht ganz so gut geht.
Ich muss heute
mit dem Kopf arbeiten.
Aber ich habe jetzt
Tabletten genommen,
in 1 Std. kommt die Wirkung,
dann geht's sicher besser.
Ich habe ein gutes Team,
nicht wahr?
Und wie geht es dem Patienten,
dem jungen Punk Cooper?
Er kann heute laufen.
Ich habe gestern
vielleicht etwas übertrieben.
Der Schnitt war nur etwa so gross.
Jetzt ist die Wunde
schon fast geschlossen.
Kein Blut.
Nur eine kleine Verletzung.
Aber du nimmst ihn in dein Team?
Ja. Ich will schauen, ob er beim
nächsten Stopp wirklich nicht hinkt.
Er liebt es zu rennen,
da wird man ihm nichts anmerken.
Er wird mir vorspielen,
dass alles gut ist.
(Barbara) Na, freust du dich?
Alles ist heute viel ruhiger
als gestern.
Eine Ruhe, die auch Barbara spürt,
die Mutter und Psychologin.
Ja, du bist ready, nicht wahr?
Als ich die Socken anzog,
kam mir wieder in den Sinn:
Hatte ich mal eine Krise,
ging ich so oft zum Hund und weinte.
Wenn sich meine Eltern
wieder mal stritten
und es zu Hause nicht so lief,
wie ich wollte.
Ich weinte ins Fell, bis alles
nass war. Das weiss ich noch.
Wir hatten auch so einen schwarzen.
Eine ähnliche Grösse wie Siska.
Ja, die letzten Jahre waren ...
schon tough.
Ich hätte
auch nie länger weggekonnt.
Mein Mann hatte ein Kavernom
und musste am Hirnstamm
und am Kleinhirn operiert werden.
Das war schon crazy.
V.a. für ihn,
und für uns alle auch.
Und ich war gerade
mit dem zweiten Kind schwanger.
Ich habe schon
ein wenig die Tendenz -
obwohl ich weiss, das sollte
man nicht -, zu verdrängen,
resp. ich bin sehr optimistisch,
manchmal auch etwas idealistisch.
Und ich glaube,
dass Trauer und negative Emotionen
auch mal Platz haben.
Dafür muss man sich Zeit lassen.
Das merkte ich gestern unterwegs.
Wir müssen schauen,
dass es sich nicht verwickelt.
* Sphärische, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Und dann geht es los - auf die
40-km-Strecke zum Aalistunturi.
Manchmal ist es an der Zeit,
aus dem Alltag ausbrechen
und seinem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzuzufügen.
(Juho) Hier durch!
Langsam runterfahren.
Komm, Armin!
Juho zieht durch - er will
den angekündigten harten Anstieg
mit den Schweizern unbedingt
noch bei Tageslicht erreichen.
Noch bleiben 2 Std.
* Sphärische, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Deshalb gibt es heute
nur eine ganz kurze Pause,
damit sich die Hunde für die bevor-
stehende Anstrengung stärken können.
(Armin) Wir geben rechte Portionen.
- Ja, wegen des Sees.
Nun geht's über den See
und nachher den Hügel rauf.
Wir haben gestern gelernt, Armin,
dass du beim Füttern
eine Bindung zu den Hunden aufbaust,
darum gebe ich deinen Hunden nichts.
Vielen Dank.
Annie.
Mh!
Fighter.
Ja! Und Winnie. Guten Appetit.
Martina, die HR-Managerin,
spürt inzwischen die Anstrengung.
Ich spüre es immer noch,
oder wieder.
Bisher ging es aber relativ gut.
Der Trail ging halt
immer wieder hoch und runter.
Jetzt gehen wir
über einen grossen See -
soweit ich weiss, sind Seen flach.
Wir sollten zu Mittag essen können
während der Fahrt über den See.
Mal schauen, wie das funktioniert.
Dann geht es buchstäblich
um die Wurst, auf den Hügel zu.
Die Hunde kennen keine Müdigkeit
und wollen weiter.
Jetzt ist wieder gut.
- Cool.
Jetzt geht es flach über den See,
glaube ich.
Und dann der letzte Aufstieg -
200 Höhenmeter.
Aber nicht wie gestern.
Da machten wir das auf einmal.
- Das macht viel aus.
Und fühlst du dich auch gut?
Die Hände?
Ja, die Hände sind schon verkrampft.
- Immer noch?
Ich muss immer dehnen.
- Das hilft?
Wenn du bewegst, hilft es?
- Ja.
Ich mache jeweils so.
Schau, mehr kann ich nicht.
- Krass. Oh, Mann.
Ich bringe sie nicht gerade hin.
- Mhm.
Ziemlich krass.
- Ja.
Ich muss heute Abend
Wärmecreme einstreichen.
Gegen diese Buckel
muss man öffnende Übungen machen.
Deshalb drehe ich mich immer so.
- Ja.
Ich bewundere dich,
wie du das machst.
Mega.
Die einjährige Mayday
ist die einzige,
die jetzt über den See
eine kurze Pause bekommt.
Sie ist zum ersten Mal
auf einer solch langen Tour dabei.
Juho will sie für den Aufstieg
auf den Aalistunturi schonen.
* Helle, perlende Musik,
Trommelschläge *
Super!
Gut!
* Jauchzer *
Damit die Huskys
nicht zu schnell werden,
müssen die Teilnehmer
dauernd auf der Bremse stehen.
Langsam! He.
Bravo!
* Jauchzer *
So schön!
* Treibende, pulsierende Klänge *
Nach dem See
setzt Juho die einjährige Mayday
wieder ins Team ein
und zieht gleich weiter.
Es ist gegen 14 Uhr und
das Licht schwindet bereits wieder.
Das Gelände wird immer unebener.
Seit 4 Std. stehen sie jetzt schon
auf dem Schlitten,
ein körperlicher
und koordinativer Kraftakt für alle,
besonders für Silvia.
* Schrei *
(Englisch) Alles in Ordnung.
Nichts passiert.
Silvia, vergiss nicht zu bremsen.
Bist du eingeschlafen?
Ich habe schon gebremst, ich bin
auf der Metallplatte gestanden.
Aber du bist vielleicht
schon etwas schläfrig unterwegs.
Die Bremse benutzen, die Bremse.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Das war ein Weckruf.
Ja, genau.
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge, Jaulen *
Erst gegen 15 Uhr erreichen sie
den Anstieg zum Aalistunturi.
Fast bei Tageslicht.
* Er lacht. *
Fast. Wir sind schon weit.
(Silvia) Wie weit noch?
Jetzt geht's nur noch hoch,
und dann sind wir da.
Kein flaches Stück mehr
von jetzt an.
1 Std.?
- Genau.
* Leises Hundejaulen *
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge *
Den 200 m steilen Anstieg
müssen sie nun im Dunkeln bewältigen,
was die Sache nicht leichter macht.
* Jauchzer *
Gegen 16 Uhr dann die Erlösung.
Es war herrlich.
Und dieses Gefühl,
wenn man oben ist. Mega cool!
Es ist so schön:
Man rennt zwischendurch mit,
und dann steigt man wieder drauf
und fährt mit den Hunden mit.
Und die haben Kraft -
unwahrscheinlich.
Es ist so steil,
und die ziehen einen einfach rauf.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Ihr Starken!
Wie gerne die schuften,
das ist beeindruckend.
Die sehen den Hügel
und man sieht ihnen an,
dass sie sich darauf freuen,
den Schlitten hochzuziehen.
Das ist beeindruckend.
Alle haben es geschafft, auch Silvia.
Am Morgen hatte ich noch eine Krise,
aber es war ja jetzt
nur noch ein letzter Hügel.
Hätte es mehrere solche gehabt,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich
einen Sitzstreik gemacht.
Jetzt bin ich schon ... am Anschlag.
Und morgen ... traue ich's mir zu,
weil ich's heute konnte.
Wenn ich heute Abend
gut zu mir schaue.
Was heisst gut zu dir schauen?
- Schlafen.
Ja.
Jemand ist der Hundefutterchef,
ein anderer schaut für das Zelt
und jemand
für das warme Wasser für uns.
Kleines.
(Michelle) Geht es noch mehr?
- (Martina) Ich halte ihn.
Trotz Müdigkeit
packen sie nun alle an
und unterstützen sich gegenseitig -
keine Spur von Chaos mehr.
Immer noch nicht gut?
- Nein, hier muss es wirklich ...
Ich glaube,
oben- und dann untendurch.
Wenn sie ziehen, hält es ja hier.
Ich meine: Wir lassen es so.
Danke, cool.
Wir haben es zusammen geschafft.
Ich habe einfach Kopfschmerzen.
Das bekomme ich schnell,
wenn ich zu wenig getrunken habe.
Normalerweise
trinke ich 2-3 l pro Tag.
Unsere Thermosflasche hat 0,75 l -
und jetzt ist noch was drin.
Aber eben, man hat keine Zeit
und muss oder darf
zuerst zu den Hunden schauen.
So hat sich das ergeben.
Und ich muss sagen:
Die Piste heute
hatte recht viele Schläge.
Das ist nicht förderlich
bei Kopfschmerzen.
Jetzt gibt's noch ein Mäntelchen.
Das haben wir auch im Programm.
Jetzt vertraue ich ihnen.
Es ist der dritte Tag.
Und mit nur wenigen Ratschlägen
funktionieren sie jetzt
gut als Team.
Es gibt keinen Grund zur Sorge mehr.
Sie haben
die Hunde richtig festgemacht,
graben Löcher für die Hunde,
helfen sich gegenseitig.
Jetzt warten wir nur noch,
bis das Essen fertig ist.
Wir könnten im Zelt auch eine
Heuunterlage gegen die Kälte machen,
wenn wir genug Heu haben.
So.
Oh, lasst sie schlafen.
Rennen, wenn es nötig ist,
schlafen, wenn sie können -
das macht
einen erfahrenen Schlittenhund aus.
Noch können sich die Teilnehmerinnen
nicht ausruhen.
Silvia hat nach diesem harten Tag
Schmerzen im Knie
und ist nicht sicher,
ob es etwas Ernstes ist.
Michelle, die Physiotherapeutin,
kümmert sich um sie.
Wenn ich hier drücke?
Ah.
- Das tut weh?
Ja, etwas.
- Und hier unten?
Au! Noch mehr.
Zum Glück habe ich die aufgerollt.
Hier?
- Au!
Und wenn ich so drücke?
- Auch.
Mein Vorschlag ist:
Ich mache dir Tape ran.
So ist es morgen stabil.
Ich mache dir eins rüber, damit
das Knie vom Gelenk her stabil ist,
dann eins auf der Seite.
Erste Entwarnung: Michelle vermutet
eine muskuläre Überlastung,
verursacht durch die ungewohnten
Bewegungen auf dem Schlitten.
Silvia hofft,
nach morgen dabei zu sein.
Auch für die alte Hundedame Chess
gibt es heute
eine willkommene Überraschung:
Statt in der Kälte bei -20 °C
darf sie mit im Zelt übernachten.
(Barbara) Schon okay,
ich kann auch unten.
Na? Bist gerade noch
etwas überfordert, nicht wahr?
Süss, schau.
Martina weiss, wie's geht.
Sie weiss, wie's geht. So ist dir
wohl. (Armin) Chess, du Verwöhnte!
(Martina) Ich hatte auch schon
Vierbeiner im Bett. - Cool.
Hündchen, schlaft gut.
Bis morgen.
Morgen geht es weiter
mit der längsten Etappe -
auf der Huskytour des Lebens.